mermet hors du palais le sénat comme
vous ne l'avez jamais entendue le texte
de loi qui vous est proposé dans tout le
monde sait qu'il est à la fois
inconstitutionnelle complexe il légal
risque beaucoup de conduire notre pays à
l'avant l'homme que vous entendez c'est
moi gaston monnerville premier président
noir du sénat qui aurait pu croire qu'un
petit fils d'esclave soit élu à la tête
de la chambre haute en 1947 voici mon
histoire
je suis né à cayenne en 1897 à 15 ans je
gagne une bourse et je quitte la guyane
pour entrer au lycée à toulouse quelques
années plus tard je suis docteur en
droit au barreau de toulouse puis à
celui de barry me voilà à vocation
chaque fois qu'il s'agit de lutter
contre une mesure où contre un régime
qui tend à détruire la justice entre les
hommes je me trouve du côté des opprimés
j'ai toujours eu à coeur de défendre et
guyanais en 1932 je deviens leurs
députés puis l'année suivante maire de
cayenne
c'est moi qui abolit le bagne en guyane
quatre ans plus tard lorsque je suis
sous secrétaire d'état aux colonies
quand la guerre éclate j'entre en
résistance et m'engage en auvergne sous
le pseudonyme de commandant saint juste
après le conflit commence ma longue
aventure sénatoriales je représente
d'abord la guyane puis le lot et suis
finalement élu à la tête de la chambre
août à l'âge de 50 ans
[Musique]
sous ma présidence je suis violemment
ému lorsque la loi consacre le transfert
de victor schoelcher et de félix éboué
au panthéon c'est alors la cohorte
nommera pas de réseau privé a créé par
ma voix devenue la leur accède à
l'immortalité pendant mes 21 ans de
présidence je défend ardemment la
démocratie parlementaire et en
particulier le rôle du cdh a eu nouveau
réforme en 1968 alors que le général de
gaulle tente par voie référendaire de
réduire leurs ondes notre assemblée je
m'y opposer démissionne de la présidence
je lui lance alors non monsieur le
président de la république vous n'avez
pas le droit vous le prenez
je reste sénateur du lot et j'accepte en
1974 de rejoindre le conseil
constitutionnel
en 91 à ma mort la presse fait de moi
l'homme qui a dit non au général de
gaulle mais j'espère surtout laisser aux
générations futures le souvenir d'un
infatigable défenseur de la liberté et
de l'égalité des droits